The Joe Rogan Experience see this is
what I'm talking about man this is the
liminal or subliminal part of the human
experience what you're talking about
right now is upsetting to people
uh but also a lot of people will say
don't even talk you're not even supposed
to say that like and and even though
it's true like even though it's in plain
sight trackable traceable precedent for
it in the past not even that like
astounding
you were supposed to like rest in this
strange dream world where
human beings
experiencing some of the most power you
can have in the world
don't go a little or totally or
completely insane or don't get hijacked
or don't get like we're supposed to
pretend that doesn't happen right when
you look at the president
look like
does Biden seem like he be hard to trick
would you even have to trick them though
maybe I mean I think
what goes on behind behind closed doors
doors don't wanna see they made it they
sent an extra bit how many billion
dollars they accidentally sent to
Ukraine
6.2 billion it was an accident they
accidentally
they accidentally sent it yeah 6.2 more
than they were supposed to well then
they just sent some more that must have
been a rough phone call that accounting
error provides an extra 6.2 billion for
Ukraine military aid whoops sorry hey
what's up it's Duncan uh look I can't
you know I kind of [__] up I was on a
little bit of ketamine when I was doing
that uh you whatever the transaction so
uh can you send back the 62 billion
dollars 6.2 6.2 billion dollars actually
sent to you can you just send it back
because you think if it's a clerical
error right
then they're gonna be like oh [__] you
know I didn't notice the 6.2 billion
dollars going into my account that's how
rich I am I'll send back there's so much
money because like at some point you
know it's just I don't even know what it
is just billions lots of billions
yeah it's pretty weird the Pentagon said
Tuesday that it overestimated the value
of the weapons it sent to Ukraine by 6.2
billion over the past two years about
double early estimates resulting in a
surplus that will be used for future
security packages oh don't worry about
it just use it for future security
packages it's a Security package it's
the Surplus what do we know man security
packages we don't know [__] and I'm
that's just saying we're going to keep
sending money forever and ever and ever
Security package
uh it'll just go back into the pot of
money that we have that we all have
allocated that's a big [__] point
future Pentagon stock drawdowns look at
that future Pentagon stock drawdowns ew
why does that sound like they're playing
a game you know what I'm saying that's
like sounds like a game Carlin's got the
ultimate bid on it man like the
evolution of War language you know it
used to be called shell shocked but then
they changed it like it's like yeah the
the whatever that language is is
inevitably
confusing it's confusing and it's also
it it has this air of authority to it
like the judge wearing the robe yeah
yeah hypnotic Yeah by by talking about
it that way stock drawdowns and you know
pentagons to allocated money it's the
same money but um in may they found
three billion more back then so I don't
know if that's 10 or if it's whoops they
just doubled with it well their
keyboard's probably broken or like it's
a mistake it's a mistake but it makes
mistakes for people but we're all doing
the right thing easy to [__] it up man
it's like we got to take it easy on
these people and again like
you if you even though it is like
mainstream news yeah that's what I like
that's so brilliant about it is that
they're just like yeah you know it's a
pot we had a pot yeah and it goes in the
same pot no big deal there's other stuff
and it goes out there everyone sees it
everyone's busy dude yeah and no one has
time to really like start thinking about
no
3.2 billion dollars uh 6.2 6.2 billion
dollars that we've all
put into that pot like is every single
person living in America has put some
dollars in that pot and some of those
dollars you know bridges are [__]
collapsing
you know it's it is should be mildly
frustrating to people mildly frustrating
to realize 6.2 billion dollars of like
fireman checks
teacher checks nurse checks the front
line workers that's that that that money
is like doesn't that matter enough to
for them to like be more careful about
it and also when they [__] up like that
where's the apology
you just blew six billion dollars of tax
money
and it was a mistake you're not keeping
like imagine if your accountant made the
same mistake just basic account
would you
keep that accountant as your accountant
and if you did you're a [__] idiot
you got to fire that account and get an
accountant who doesn't like misplace
so much money right yeah and especially
if the accountant didn't apologize it
was just like oh right well do you see
we have a different pot where some of
your money it's a pot thing it's
allocated
do you know how complex our pot system
is you should see it I've got a thousand
pots back there varying sizes we did
change according to astrological uh
shifts don't even worry about it it's
just a pot
I kind of gotta go okay
come on like it's so frustrating it's so
frustrating it's it's very wild dude
very it's very wild that they just keep
printing money
jacking up the inflation printing money
I love that one because mixed into the
printing money thing which obviously
have money printers what's really funny
about that is somehow people believe
that
that money is like doesn't go just right
hot off the press to like people in the
building like or that it doesn't like
some of that money gets shifted around
and like you know or some of it is
printed and I know I'm sure there's like
no there's Securities in place
we have Securities in place it's
numbered we've got come on